the Joe Rogan experience did you like
Fear Factor more than cuz I remember I
loved Newsradio mmm my favorite shows so
did you enjoy that more a fear factor
they're different things they're
definitely different things I enjoyed
the paycheck from Fear Factor far more I
liked working without actors but I loved
Newsradio way more Newsradio was just a
farm show so it was really well they're
different things they're very different
animals it ruined me it would it would
it's like going from the comi store to
Uncle [ __ ] sticks chuckle hut uh-huh and
on Monday night you know it's like every
other sitcom that I looked at every
other sitcom that a read for or that I
got scripts for rather just not good
stuff isn't interesting when you get
sides like just sides or just like one
scene or two scenes for a show and you
could tell it's good just on that oh
yeah that's so rare it is rare yeah yeah
when someone's a good writer good sitcom
writing is hard to do man there's a
really hard gig I mean there's a and
then but then some people have bad
sitcom writing but they know how to make
a bad successful sitcom like there's bad
successful sitcom to last forever
they're just unoffensive enough to stay
on the air and keep you watching with
your mouth slack yeah I mean formulas
exist for a reason those big bearing
kids they're so they're so clever with
their writing that's what keeps this guy
ever shut off CBS your TV has other
channels sir what yeah there's other
channels other programming to watch well
when they took Bill O'Reilly off the air
hit CBS my channel yeah you ever been in
the like an audition and it's terrible
but everyone goes through the motions
where everyone's just like cracking up
like it's oh it's a greatest show on
earth
yeah Oh like it's Def Jam like because
the writers and the directors in the
room like the fake laugh to get
everybody excited yeah they have to
because I think they need this rocket
fuel to get this project off the ground
yes and they need to give the writer
confidence they have to give the
director compliment they have to give
the studio people confidence that it's
all good
it's a
fake moment the fake laugh it's gross
and the thing is though like it's also
not only the girl but it's a 30th time
there's just because there's 30 people
in the waiting room mm-hmm and they're
laughing like it's the first time
they're faking it left and right and we
know fake laugh we do it's offensive
someone's fake laughing at you it's
almost worse than Chanel laughs it is
worse than not laugh you know have you
say joking they're like haha okay like
get him out get you get out of here you
bad person
yeah you you you you you it's the
quickest way to heckle oh right just
like ah what I'm laughing yeah it's like
the Fredo thing no I was afraid of that
thing you're afraid of did you see that
yeah of course did you see that Chris
Cuomo guy said Donald Trump had the best
line today
Donald Trump won the Internet today with
this he said should we red flag Chris
Cuomo because he seemed unhinged he look
it was using terrible language should
not have a gun he basically exposed
those red flag laws just like you see a
guy like that he's irrational that guy's
irrational he goes I'll wreck your [ __ ]
I'll throw you down stairs with stairs
comment that was I enjoyed that look
what is he talking about cuz a guy
called you Fredo and he was saying the
prenup same things the n-word I didn't
know Fredo was drug Tory or maybe I'm
new to it I just I'm not that I would
ever try to call someone Fredo sometimes
it's not it's a [ __ ] character in a
movie it's like a Latin is it like
there's no like I don't know it's real
Kanye I'm Italian
there's no cultural context for Fredo
where people look what the [ __ ] did you
say it doesn't exist it does not exist
right well you could say it for someone
who's a traitor but what that doesn't
even make sense with Chris Cuomo it's
just it's just a loser you know in a
movie well I guess I go you know what
he's trying to do I mean obviously he's
trying to insult him yes even if there
is no history of this word existing for
you know I mean I don't know if it does
exist or not but like you know this
guy's trying to take shots it's
certainly not a compliment
sure yeah I mean it's a loser in a movie
it's a
brother that always fell short and he
turned it turned on his own brother who
was the Godfather
what is he wanted to be the Godfather
did he explain this insult to Chris
Cuomo that would be great those Fredo
was a weak Italian in the movie and I am
referencing your character yes you are
the son of a great man because you know
he's Mario Cuomo's son and you probably
you know let's let's be honest about why
you're here yeah you know the name is
familiar and you know it helps yeah but
it's it's that Italian energy that like
again yeah is it my full Italian no 3/4
though but these people that that react
that way are common it's like what what
the [ __ ] did you say to me I'll [ __ ]
wreck your [ __ ] yeah but you're not
supposed to be a respected political
pundit and behave like that that is
nonsense
you know that's nonsense that's nonsense
so it's a silly way to behave it's silly
that guy needs to work out he works out
it's tough it's tough when it be on too
much testosterone so we need to take him
to tell the doctor just pair you down a
little bit take whatever you had just
drop it by half
settle down bro or just work out really
hard before you go outside uh-huh do
some yoga meditate I like when those
because I always pretty passive town for
the most part you'll get some of those
you'll get like an East Coast guy who's
is that Nolan a Fredo
yeah we don't actually fight here we
just go get my shine box yeah it's um it
was a very embarrassing moment think
it's a very important moment look at him
first of all he is Fredo
for life now I hope he understands that
he's Fredo for life unless you want to
get tossed down a flight of stairs
he ain't tossing anybody down a flight
of stairs that's nonsense he doesn't
want to get sued he's not gonna do that
I'm gonna touch somebody he'll hire
someone not doing [ __ ] not doing a
goddamn thing that's one of the reasons
why it's so funny he's not doing nothing
this that is Fredo you'll never get away
from that now better embrace that [ __ ]
better starts off Rado t-shirts with
your face
listen CNN's probably gonna fire him
outta me I think they're standing behind
us get the [ __ ] outta ya are they really
friend I think they felt like he was
attacked or unprovoked and yeah but
someone calling afraid oh yeah man look
up fighting words dude someone called me
Fredo I'm even Italian hot snap I go how
dare you he he's a silly man that that's
what would exposes him and said he's a
silly man it wasn't like someone was
being equally aggressive to him and he
was defending himself sometimes like if
you're in a situation where someone's
very aggressive to you you almost have
to be aggressive back just to let them
know hey I'll go there with you yes we
could we could go to a dark place right
now and you know I'm not gonna let you
hit me I'm not gonna let you do
something to me if you think that I'm a
pushover you know I'm here to defend
myself but that wasn't that way like
someone was mocking him and he turned
violent I think it was a little bit of
operation where he just wanted to get a
rise and he was recording from down low
they wanted him to do something Chris
Cuomo this is CNN CNN's lost their
[ __ ] mind Chris Cuomo defended
himself when he was verbally attacked
with the use of an ethnic slur in an
orchestrated setup the spokesperson said
we completely support him for now listen
to me this is not done this is not done
this is just beginning to take on a form
of its own you can't you can't say
that's an ethnic slur that is a [ __ ]
character in a movie news to me no it's
not about it's not and him saying that
that's like calling it the n-word that
is so preposterous that is so
offensively stupid do you ever get that
like people trying take shots or get you
to slip or something most people are
nice yes I've had guys say get goofy
[ __ ] to me and I try to say goofy [ __ ]
back till I get shadows or just on the
street it was in both things but I'm not
enough I'm not a hostile person yeah I
look hostile yeah but I'm not hostile
like I'm nice for the most I've had
people get deke with me no what do you
do how do you handle it get deke back
[Applause]